[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland eurem truecrime Podcast mein
Name ist Mirko Kasimir und ich bin Toni
Heyer hallo zusammen heute widmen wir
uns einem Fall der mich persönlich bis
heute wirklich sehr sehr bewegt nach
einem Popkonzert von Ariana Grande
explodiert am 22 mai 2017 in Manchester
im Vereinigten Königreich eine Bombe ein
Selbstmordattentäter sprengt sich in die
Luft und reißt 22 weitere Menschen mit
in den Tod viele von ihnen sind nicht
einmal 20 Jahre alt das Leid was den
Familien und Angehörigen angetan wurde
das ist unvorstellbar aber wie die
Künstlerin Ariana Grande ihre Fans und
die Stadt Manchester mit dieser
furchtbaren Tragödie umgegangen sind das
berührt wirklich sehr denn gemeinsam
werden sie zeigen hast wird niemals
siegen Liebe und Zusammenhalt sind
stärker
es ist der 22 mai 2017 in Manchester
dieser warme Montag endet im Nordwesten
Englands mit einem herrlich lauen
Sommerabend direkt neben dem Fluss er
will steht die Manchester Arena eine
große Halle bis zu 21.000 Menschen haben
Platz regelmäßig finden hier Konzerte
und Sportveranstaltungen statt direkt
neben der Halle ist die U-Bahn-Station
Victoria von dort hat man direkten
Zugang zu Arena
Überwachungskameras zeichnen auf wie ein
junger Mann einen Bahnsteig bei Victoria
Station entlang läuft und weiter durch
die Hallen der Bahnstation wandert er
ist dunkel angezogen er trägt eine
schwarze Hose einen dunklen Pullover
eine schwarze Weste und eine graue auf
seinem Rücken trägt er einen großen
schwarzen Rucksack dieser ist schwer
um das Gewicht auszubalancieren ist der
Oberkörper des jungen Mannes nach vorne
gelehnt
der Mann ist Salman a baby und in seinem
Rucksack ist eine selbstgebaute Bombe
Abedi steigt in einen Fahrstuhl der ihn
direkt von der Bahnstation in die
Manchester Arena fährt
Abdi scheint nervös er nimmt seine Kappe
vom Kopf nur um sie unmittelbar wieder
aufzusetzen schaut nach unten und
überprüft Kabel an seinem Gürtel seinem
Sprengstoffgürtel
Abdi läuft in die Vorhalle der
konzert-arena er passiert dabei
Polizisten und Security Männer doch sie
nehmen den 23-jährigen Mann gar nicht
wahr im Vorraum der Konzerthalle die
auch City Hall genannt wird läuft Abdi
die schnurst auf die Treppe zu geht die
Stufen bis nach oben und setzt sich hin
er weiß dass sie Überwachungskameras der
Manchester Arena hier nicht sehen werden
es ist ein blinder Fleck im System ab
jetzt wartet Abi es ist 21:33 Uhr hinter
den Türen der City Hall nur wenige Meter
von Abedi entfernt jubeln mehr als 14000
Fans der amerikanischen Popsängerin
Ariana Grande zu es sind vor allem
Kinder mit ihren Eltern und Jugendliche
für viele von ihnen ist es das erste
Konzert ihres Lebens seit 21 Uhr steht
die 23-Jährige auf der Bühne im Rahmen
ihrer Welttournee gibt die pop diva ihre
größten Hits wie into you
oder one last time zum Besten
[Musik]
um 22 Uhr ist das Konzert vorbei die
Lichter in der Manchester Arena gehen an
tausende glückliche Fans strömen
Richtung Ausgang die Stimmung ist
ausgelassen rosa Luftballons liegen in
den Zuschauerrängen aus den
Lautsprechern Tönen Ariana Grande Lieder
bis plötzlich
[Applaus]
wenige Sekunden zuvor ist Abdi von den
Stufen aufgestanden und in die Mitte des
Foyers gelaufen vorbei an den ersten
Fans die aus der Arena Strömen und
Eltern die ihre Kinder nach dem
Konzertbesuch abholen wollen
Abdi schaut auf sein Handy er lächelt
und sprengt sich in die Luft
vor jede Arena liegen viele Verletzte
und Tote
Zeugenberichten von blutigen Körpern und
abgetrennten Körperteil in der
Konzerthalle bricht eine Massenpanik aus
Menschenmengen Rennen raus aus der Arena
Richtung Bahnhof schreien um Hilfe
schreien in Todesangst
Abedi tötet 22 Menschen sein jüngstes
Opfer ist noch ein Kind ein kleines
Mädchen gerade einmal acht Jahre alt
zehn seine Opfer sind unter 20 Jahren es
ist der tödlichste Anschlag im
Vereinigten Königreich seit dem
bombenanten Tat in London im Jahr 2005
jedes Attentat ist grässlich furchtbar
und vor allem traurig aber dieses hier
das ist so unfassbar böse ein gezielter
Anschlag auf kleine Kinder und
Jugendliche unschuldige Menschen
umzubringen die einen schönen Abend
haben und ihr dohl endlich mit eigenen
Augen sehen wollten das ist so perfide
[Musik]
bevor wir weiter über die Folgen dieses
Attentats sprechen widmen wir uns dem
Täter und seiner Herkunft denn dieses
Attentat hätte verhindert werden können
hätten die Behörden Hinweise und
Warnungen ernst genommen Werbung
wir kriegen ja immer wieder Fragen von
euch rein was ihr denn eigentlich
abgesehen von Podcast zu machen was wir
so privat anstellen ob wir da auch
andere Interessensgebiete haben und ich
sage ganz klar nein in meiner Freizeit
verbringe ich gerne viel Zeit vom
Fernseher irgendwie True Crime Dokus
Krimis etc ich bin ein ganz großer Doku
Fan und Marktes halt wenn ich irgendwie
nach einem stressigen Tag nach Hause
komme oder aus dem Studio gehe und mit
einem Abend irgendwie mich von der
schönen Doku berieseln lasse oder sogar
ich gebe zu auch ein bisschen Trash TV
schauen ja bei mir ist das Problem ein
bisschen dass ich überhaupt gar keine
richtigen Sender habe das heißt ich kann
halt wirklich nur über Apps oder
Mediatheken gucken und wenn ich halt so
richtig Fernsehprogramm will muss ich
halt zu meiner Tante rüber in die
Wohnung bei mir ist das eigentlich ich
habe einen Fernseher zum Glück ja ich
muss nicht zu meiner Tante oder zu
meinem Onkel gehen ich habe einen
Fernseher hast du richtig mit Sendern so
richtig mit seiner bei mir ist halt nur
das Problem dass es dann manchmal Streit
was heißt Streit aber dann gibt's halt
manchmal Diskussion darüber was man denn
gerade sehen will ja der eine möchte da
ist der andere das und du geht es hin
und her also der berühmte Streit um die
Fernbedienung genau den könnt ihr euch
aber ersparen denn mit o2 TV könnt ihr
ganz einfach übers Internet schauen da
findet ihr über 130 TV-Sender in HD und
ihr könnt auch bis zu 100 Stunden an
Live-Sendungen Serien und so weiter
einfach aufnehmen oder Filme anhalten
und später weiterschauen und das gute
ist Mirko ihr müsst euch nicht mehr
prügeln was ihr gucken wollt denn mit o2
TV funktionieren bis zu vier
unterschiedliche Geräte gleichzeitig und
das nicht nur zu Hause sondern auch
unterwegs und das beste o2 TV gibt es
jetzt sogar inklusive Netflix das ist
natürlich ein super Angebot denn ich bin
ja ein riesengroßer Rick und Morty Fan
und auch die Office das sind beides
Serien die bei mir in meiner Netflix
watch schließt ganz ganz oben stehen ich
werde immer in meinem Freundeskreis ein
bisschen gehänselt dass ich noch nie
diese US-Serie shameless gesehen habe
die gab es aber bisher noch nicht auf
Netflix seit dem 1 September haben sie
alle 11 Staffeln drauf geballert und das
sage ich dir am nächsten Wochenende wird
da richtig durchgesucht also falls ihr
die Serie auch noch nicht kennt als es
eure Chance guckt ihr euch mal unbedingt
an also Bucht jetzt o2 TV für günstige
9,99 € im Monat und erhalte 12 Monate
Netflix geschenkt geht dafür einfach auf
o2.de/go2/ Tatort also o2.de/got
/ Tatort TA t o r t und sichert euch mit
o2 TV und Netflix das Beste aus live
Fernsehen und Streaming als Paket alle
Infos und den link zum Angebot den
findet ihr auch in unserem Show Notes
und ihr wisst ja Leute o2 Kendo
Werbung Ende aber der Reihe nach soll
man Abedi wird in Manchester geboren
seine Eltern sind aus Libyen vor dem
damaligen Machthaber mohamma al Gaddafi
ins Vereinigte Königreich geflohen denn
salmans Vater ist Mitglied der
islamistischen Terrorgruppe namens
Libyen islamik fighting Group die in
enger Verbindung mit al-Qaida steht die
islamistische Gesinnung des Vaters färbt
auf Salman und seinen kleinen Bruder
Haschem ab im Jahr 2011 ziehen die
Eltern zurück nach Libyen die beiden
Brüder Reisen sogar mit in das
nordafrikanische Land um gegen der
Duffys Truppen zu kämpfen Salman ist da
gerade erst mal 16 Jahre alt in den
darauffolgenden Jahren reisen die Brüder
immer wieder zwischen Libyen und dem
Vereinigten Königreich hin und her sogar
als der islamische Staat im Jahr 2014
seinen Kalifat ausruft sieht es die
beiden Brüder zurück im selben Jahr wird
Salman ein subject of interest also eine
Person von Interesse für das britische
Innenministerium weil er eine
Freundschaft zu einem radikalen
Islamisten pflegt mindestens fünf Mal
sollen bekannte des Attentäters die
britischen Behörden gewarnt haben das
Abedi krankenideologien anhing und
möglicherweise plante diese in die Tat
umzusetzen unter anderem soll Abedi
gesagt haben dass er Selbstmordattentate
okay fände und obwohl die Behörden
mehrmals gewarnt wurden machen Sie
nichts gar nichts Salman Abedi reiste im
April 2017 noch einmal nach Libyen hier
sollen die radikalen Brüder mutmaßlich
Utensilien und Anweisungen zum Bomben
bauen gegeben worden sein und am 18 mai
2017 fünf Tage vor dem Attentat Rest sei
man zurück nach Manchester sein Bruder
bleibt bei der Familie in Libyen
nachdem Salman sich und 22 unschuldige
in die Luft sprengt bekennt sich der
islamische Staat zur Tat im Vereinigten
Königreich werden daraufhin am nächsten
Tag mindestens 13 Personen festgenommen
die in Beziehung zur thermiliz stehen in
Libyen nehmen die Behörden salmans Vater
und Bruder Haschem fest
letzterer bekennt sich gegenüber den
Ermittlern offen zum is bestätigt
außerdem dass er alles über die Pläne
seines Bruders wusste und maßgeblich an
den Vorbereitungen des Attentats
beteiligt war Libyen lieferter im Jahr
2019 nach England aus ein Jahr später
wird er damals 22-jährige verurteilt
nach Auffassung des Richters kaufte
Haschem die Chemikalien für den
Sprengsatz bastelte die Zünder und
kaufte den Wagen in dem die Teile für
die Bombe bis zu ihrem Zusammenbau
lagerten
seine Strafe mindestens 55 Jahre Haft
die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist hoch das nie
wieder in Freiheit sein wird
doch zurück zu diesem verheerenden 22
mai 2017
Notärzte sind bis um 2 Uhr nachts am
Tatort verarzten verletzte versuchen
Leben zu retten fünf Stunden nach der
tödlichen Detonation twietet Ariana
Grande gebrochen aus tiefstem Herzen tut
es mir so leid mir fehlen die Worte
weltweit gibt es Beileidsbekundungen
unter anderem Taylor Swift Bruno Mars
und Justin Bieber melden sich bei
Twitter die Menschen sind fassungslos
darüber dass ein Popkonzert zum
Anschlagsziel wurde auch Politiker
äußern sich Frankreichs Präsident macron
bietet dem Vereinigten Königreich Hilfe
an die Stadt Manchester das ganze
Königreich steht unter Schock wieder ein
Terroranschlag wieder ein Terroranschlag
der ausgeübt wird während Menschen Spaß
haben das Leben genießen sich frei
fühlen wieder ein Terroranschlag der
westliche arbeitet zerstören soll doch
die Menschen in Manchester wollen sich
nicht unterkriegen lassen und in Angst
leben bereits am Tag nach der tödlichen
Attacke kommen viele Überlebende zurück
zum Tatort und gedenken der Opfer Ariana
Grande reist unmittelbar nach dem
Konzert zurück in ihre Heimat Florida in
den USA Fotos zeigen sie bei ihrer
Ankunft in Schwarz gekleidet der Blick
gesenkt sichtlich mitgenommen eigentlich
sollte die Popsängerin weiter durch
Europa touren ihre Auftritte sagt Ariana
Grande jedoch ab dann taucht sie unter
anderthalb Wochen später veröffentlicht
Ariana einen emotionalen Brief bei
Instagram darin schreibt die 23-Jährige
unter anderem es tut mir leid für den
Schmerz und die Angst die ihr Empfinden
müsst und für das Trauma dass ihr
durchleben müsst wir werden nie in der
Lage sein zu verstehen warum solche
Dinge geschehen denn es liegt nicht in
unserer Natur und deshalb sollten wir
nicht zurückschrecken
wir werden nicht aufgeben oder in Angst
handeln wir werden nicht zulassen dass
uns das in zweit wir werden nicht
zulassen dass der Hass siegt und sie
gibt außerdem bekannt dass sie nach
Manchester zurückkehren wird um ein
Benefizkonzert mit dem Titel One Love
Manchester zu geben die ticket-erlöse
und Spenden gehen an die Familien und
Angehörigen des Attentats aber Ariana
Grande wird nicht allein auftreten
unterstützung erhält sie von den
absoluten Stars der Musikbranche die
Tickets für das Benefizkonzert sind nach
20 Minuten ausverkauft wobei nicht ganz
komplett denn jeder der ihr Konzert in
Manchester am 22 Mal besuchte der kriegt
ein Ticket in der ersten Reihe umsonst
am 4 juni keine zwei Wochen nach dem
tödlichen Anschlag ist es dann soweit
[Applaus]
50.000 Menschen stehen in einem Stadion
dicht
viele halten Schilder mit I have
Manchester also ich liebe Manchester in
die Höhe das Konzert wird in mindestens
38 Länder weltweit übertragen allein im
Vereinigten Königreich schauen
durchschnittlich fast elf Millionen
Menschen die drei stündige
Veranstaltungen im Fernsehen neben
Ariana Grande performen unter anderem
Robbie Williams Take That Coldplay
Williams Justin Bieber Miley Cyrus und
Katy Perry
doch für den emotionalsten Moment sorgt
die Gastgeberin Ariana Grande selbst als
die Dunkelheit über Manchester einbricht
stellte sich mit ihrer Band auf die
Bühne die Instrumente sind mit Blumen
geschmückt normalerweise ist Ariana
stark geschminkt und trägt aufwendige
knappe Kostüme auf der Bühne doch an
diesem Tag trägt sie eine Jeans und
einen weißen Pullover unter tosendem
Applaus beginnt sie das Lied over the
rainbow zu singen ein Tribut an ihre
Verstorbenen Fans
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die Menschen im Publikum und die
Sängerin Weinen es ist ein intimer und
emotionaler Moment zwischen Ariana
Grande und ihren Fans
geeint in Trauer und Trauma in dem
Moment scheinen die anderen Zuschauer im
Stadion und weitere Millionen zu Hause
ganz weit weg anstatt sich von der Angst
und dem Hass unterkriegen zu lassen
kehrt Ariana Grande zurück Liebe ist
stärker als Hass das hat das
Benefizkonzert definitiv gezeigt
anstatt sich vor Menschenmengen zu
fürchten beweisen Überlebende und
Angehörige Mut dafür haben sie alle
definitiv mein tiefsten Respekt drei
Millionen Pfund also 3,5 Millionen Euro
an Spenden werden allein nur während des
Konzerts gesammelt drei Tage nach dem
Benefizkonzert steht Ariana Grande
wieder auf der Bühne dieses Mal in Paris
aber das Manchester Attentat begleitet
sie bis heute die Sängerin erzählt offen
von ihren dadurch entstandenen
Panikattacken und ihr posttraumatischen
Belastungsstörung
wir haben jetzt sehr viel über den Täter
die Überlebenden und Ariana Grande
gesprochen zum Abschluss möchten wir
aber noch den Opfern gedenken das waren
vor allem Fans die Spaß haben und das
Leben genießen wollten aber auch Eltern
deren größte Sorge vielleicht war das
ihre Kinder alleine auf ein Konzert
gehen und sie nur abholen und sicher
nach Hause bringen wollten sie alle
wurden gewaltsam und völlig unerwartet
aus dem Leben gerissen
und damit sind wir am Ende unserer
heutigen Ausgabe von Tatort Deutschland
zurück bleibt ein beklemmendes Gefühl
wir haben unsere heutige Ausgabe mit
Quellen der BBC dem Guardian und Sky
News erzählt ich hoffe Ihr seid auch
beim nächsten Mal mit dabei bis dahin
passt auf euch auf eure Toni und euer
Mirko